qu'est-ce qui seraient volontaires pour
commencer par bien brossé les joints
quoi de nombreux volontaires sur ce
chantier spéciale au coeur de la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet
objectif de la semaine construire un
four à pain bas la fois je suis mélangé
la terre règle au talent et la cour va
pour que c'est ça devrait être pas mal
ils sont douze enfants entre 8 et 11 ans
à venir de toute la france pour
participer à ce séjour dans le cadre de
l'opération c'est mon patrimoine
une semaine de vacances avec des
ateliers des activités sont plutôt très
rythmée sur sur la journée mais le décès
de leur faire faire une vraie activité
une vraie découverte de techniques
traditionnelles dont la construction
d'un four à pain au mortier de chaux à
la terre aux depuis l'eau et ils
apprennent ça tout au long de la semaine
la moitié d'entre eux participent pour
la deuxième fois charmé par une première
édition l'année dernière déjà dernière
dans les tentes a fait un rigolo c'est
assez amusant
après le salut on apprend des choses
plus loin activités sculpture sur pierre
elena s'applique sur sa tortue barry
creuser est ainsi en train de faire les
pattes faut d'abord tracé avec un truc
comme ça
et après il faut retracer avec un crayon
comme sa pierre ce soir ce sera
activités cuisine pour nos apprentis
artisans histoire de savoir quoi mettre
dans ce four à pain avant de repartir
chez leurs parents dans deux jours